foreign
[Applause]
thank you are you excited to be here I
am buddy I remember I came here um when
you were setting this up you're like I
think I want to run a podcast Studio no
you said I want to start a podcast let's
go on a hike you should go to Malaysia
for three months I did say you should
get lost did you say I'm about to start
a podcast I'm like that's the right time
to go then you haven't started anything
yet you're the only person when I hang
out with uh that tells me to work less
instead of comes to me with like weird I
was like so Ari is like let's go on this
hike I'm like I'm either getting
murdered by Ari or uh we're on a date
I'm not sure exactly and normally when a
comedian I go on a hike with them or
they trick me into some like coffee date
and there's always a pitch there's a
Damocles sword hanging of like the
countdown for when I'm gonna get pitched
like a family sitcom about your zany
yeah like gay Uncle yeah and it just
never came but you were like you know
what you need to do go to Laos yeah for
a year at least I said at least three
months I said it very minimum like two
to four weeks but probably three months
or more I feel like you're one of the
few people in comedy who see
uh like whatever thing I have I don't
know you can diagnose me and you're like
I'm gonna try to help her oh yeah yeah
is it the guilt from stealing my
backpack yeah yeah 15 years ago also I
stole a dollar out of that I never told
you
um yeah no I I don't know I don't which
your world is like overlapped my world
but you make your money in a world I'm
not in so I don't really want anything
from you I always ask people when they
come in for the first time uh are we
friends yeah we're friends
if somebody's like if I'm on a plane and
somebody's like uh do you know when he
Comics I'll be like yes my friend hear
what I mean I feel like we're like
closer than that though
well what am I supposed to say yeah
that's my best friend
do you not say that to people that's my
best friends DeRose always does this one
of my dearest friends said I'm like shut
up dude you sound like a fucking
Hollywood but it is weird when you're
like in what other business Fred that's
a big thing it is a big thing yeah but
in what other business do you spend so
much time together yet none at all but
when you do it's more oddly well we have
a clubhouse yes so we can be like so
when I'm in L.A I don't I could I can
call one or two people but I'm like I'll
just see most people I saw Ian Edwards
at the store lesson I'd have to call
them yeah but we gotta do a 10 minute
talk yeah it was just like you you'll
see your friends at this at the store
yeah
so like yeah
we're not like oh shit are you in New
York we gotta have lunch we're not that
kind of friend well that's the weird
thing about Comics is like I find myself
never making plans with the ones I like
the most because I assume I'm just going
to run into them yeah but then sometimes
you don't and then or take it for
granted granted yeah is that what we do
yeah we're just like we'll see you
um I feel like we've been through a lot
together uh-huh kind of yeah we thought
the dark days of the store they call it
which was really the brightest days I
want to go back to that in a second but
first I want to just go to your special
really quick thank you your special Jew
is out now it's out how fucking lucky
are you that Kanye West oh my gosh
trying to push Jews off buildings right
now I was just like people are like
what's this about I'm like it's very
interesting timing I'm planning it for
years and I didn't know but this is like
Sebastian Maniscalco one of the greatest
Comics ever we love but you know when he
was first getting big you know I don't
think you can separate the fact that it
was right when like jurors he sure was
coming out and he was right he was sort
of the antidote to Jersey Shore yeah
right it was a Zeitgeist thing that
maybe helped push him up
but also he capitalized by being great
no he's the best but it got more people
to get eyeballs on so at least give it a
chance yeah because people were like
wait that's not how Italian people are
and then he was sort of like you know he
hosted MTV Awards with like Snooki it
kind of worked this feels like yeah I
remember marketing class they were like
it's not build a better mousetrap and
people will build a will beat a patio
door it's build a better mousetrap and
get the word out and then people will
build up you know yeah because I feel
like Kanye dude you've been working on
this I feel like for a long time yeah
and a long time five years of
intentional work on one working special
so like yeah and now I put it away for
like a year plus for covet and took it
out and figured out all the fucking
jokes that are too long and so I could
see it fresh again trying to start doing
always now but like
yeah then Kanye comes in right at the
fucking Finish Line at the buzzer yeah
you know these motherfuckers I'm like
what let me ask you let's get ahead one
of the greatest fucking songs of all
time I feel like
um
what is going on what like why at the
craziest level of someone's like when
someone is uh at their most mentally ill
Why are Jews always the it all all roads
of conspiracy lead to Jews is it because
there's so few Jews in the world that
they think they're gonna get the least
amount of blowback is it because that
some take the day off from technology so
they assume they're not going to see the
tweets it's both the hate predated like
our Orthodox she was even seeing these
tweets on Fridays yeah no they're not uh
they're not even hearing about it
they're just fuck you know they're just
watching their stocks go up
yeah why is that Holtzman I saw this
Comics like funny Angry comic he has
some lady in the crowd he's like he's
like what are you she's I'm Jewish it
was 15 years ago he goes why does
everybody hate you and she goes I don't
know you never thought to ask if
everybody hated me I I at least
questioned yeah I don't know my mom is
annoying so I you know I get it Kanye
but isn't it sort of just the as the
economy sort of goes down the toilet and
things get divisive it's an easy thing
to go to because very few people know
Jews and maybe they rely on that yeah so
we're Outsiders we've always kept to
ourselves and so like uh even the really
good um you know promoters of the
Holocaust what's his name as in
publicists yeah who's the Holocaust
publicist
gerbils yeah I think it was him I don't
know but he goes I don't give a shit
about Jews but they'll do well to drive
people against somebody and now the left
and the right they just have each other
usually right right it's
that's what it is because it's the same
thing I'm working on this stuff uh jokes
about like you know people hating trans
people and drag queens it's very easy to
hate them because most people don't know
you don't even know one you've never
even seen one shut up so it's easy to be
like you know and like you don't even
think about sort of the logistics of it
so the ignorance of the base of like
when people are like oh well this uh
drag queen was in a public bathroom with
my kid for two minutes it's like that's
not enough time that's not enough yeah
it takes longer to take off the pan like
you have no idea how drag works if you
think of first of all drag means like
everything not only do they not want to
fuck your kid like they think your kids
look ugly like if you met a dragon like
David everybody's like gays are gonna
try dude why you do this you're a four
they think your kids
you don't even work hours like you're
getting so like to me when parents are
like obsessed with their kids getting
molested like the trans people are gonna
get my it's like all you're doing is
telling people you think you're good
yeah you see the best in your child you
think your kid is like worth going to
jail for hot but we see him as a hopeful
school shooting victim
fucking your kid's ugly why is everybody
hating Asians for coughing and not these
fucking kids
so that's so like I'm just curious
someone that I always knew I or people
always told me I was Jewish and I just
didn't know but I am half half children
I guess yeah
like a David Duchovny joke oh am I yeah
is that where the sex addiction comes in
are you addicted to the sex I don't
think so I think I'm the opposite I
think I have this sexual anorexia thing
you go without yeah you're wild though
am I you're undercover wild really what
is that is
[Laughter]
so do you feel like there's ever one
time at band camp lady
no it's like one time I reached or two
feathers
I've actually never dated a comic really
you do you believe me or no I do I've
dated one English one well why do you
look up there then I'm just trying to
think
yeah I I haven't yeah yeah you know you
know because here's one thing about me I
don't lie
right you know what I mean and there's
all these rumors about me and I just I'm
happy to yeah you're one of those people
like I'll admit if I farted but it's so
much it wasn't me yeah it's like as soon
as I get a facelift dude everyone's good
to know it's gonna be a paid partnership
with Neosporin yeah there's gonna be a
paid partnership with staples you get
your eyes you gotta get something done
you come in looking different sometimes
yeah oh but it's actually like I mean
I've never got my eyes done I've gotten
Botox here Botox I've got Botox around
my eyes and I get a little filler on the
side of my nose yeah you know and then
sometimes I lose weight and gain weight
and then I look different yeah you know
and then I do all Thera which is like a
laser and then I got my tits done three
times I didn't have any money left for
anything else I remember you I remember
tiny tit Whitney yeah do you yeah yeah I
really with the backpack I really these
are better thank you yeah money well
spent all right did you notice when I
had fake foods like did you know oh yeah
right away yeah you normally so many
people looked at and then suddenly like
oh there's more to look at
you know we need so much bouncier I did
notice all of a sudden one day people
that didn't like me started hugging me
yeah if David Taylor tucks his shirt in
no one knows you know but like exactly
kind of hug you longer they're leading
it upper an upper hug instead of a lower
you hated me like are you pickpocketing
me are you what is happening
but like I I'm sort of interested in
Like Comics that haven't been able to
like break down like we did it on your
podcast once when I did your podcast in
New York we like broke down I love that
Comics that aren't dating spend more
time talking about the relationships
than any marriage yeah marriage people
are just fine they just roll with it
we're like remember that time that
really hurt my feelings when you did
that and I just feel like
dude my favorite was the 50th
Anniversary people working out their 30
year old shit with each other they're
petty stuff that they haven't let go
uh-huh and it was like you know that
time you brought and as is coming out of
their mouth they realize how dumb it is
that time he brought me up it was really
bullshit in 1987. do you remember that
hold it on to this four do you remember
that time we were Flappers yeah
and the guy with the dollhouse on his
head had just bombed okay and I had an
agent there from Gersh okay you do this
I was like yeah I was 22. and you
introduced me as are you guys ready for
a lady yeah and then I age shit it's
like that's why you ate shit right oh
yeah for six months you ever hear this
saying um success has many mothers but
failures are bastard
people always blame it it's one thing
that stop you from succeeding and the
double meaning of it's a bastard but
like it's oh that if that hadn't
happened that'd be big but like a lot of
people helping you along the way was
what helped you so true well what's
yours do you think or what was you I'm
doing great
can I tell you something I have always
thought this and I don't know if this is
going to come off like well or not who
cares you've made up my mind about
um you made up your mind about me I have
always been like even from the beginning
when I didn't know that much about
comedy I was like he is like our Rodney
Dangerfield I was like he's I was like
he's gonna be the most famous person in
the world in like 25 years
not even late hit I just was like the
way that this guy is so um radically
himself and not pandering to anyone like
he refuses
to like like uh compromise what he wants
to say to get a he would rather eat shit
and kill with the Germans in the front
row yeah and make the comics in the back
laugh then do some bullshit joke that he
knows will work right right right does
that make you feel like I'll find my
audience that I'm gonna be me and then
when the trends go to the other way it's
like well I'm just not on that train
yeah you know but that you know and I I
might Byron Allen explained this to me
once but what is it you only need two
million people in the world to fuck with
you to be like a millionaire as a
comedian it is Whitney I don't know if
you're saying that's that's a hella
amount of people but it's also not it is
it's not impossible but between being on
three podcasts if you go on Joe Rogan
your mom's house and Tim Dillon's show
you are words out that's easily two
million people yeah for sure they just
have to find you and go to your that's
like I like this guy totally and just go
oh he happens to me in my town and then
he happens to I happen to have the
Groupon to go see him it's so funny when
you see comics and comparing themselves
to each other and be like well that
guy's doing this I should do what they
do or I should start doing you know Lip
Sync songs and Tick Tock and I'm like
dude that's for Mateo that's not for you
It's Tricky you're not gonna do that
well it's just not your thing but Comics
like I do think that this is something
that helped me that I heard early on
yeah which is that um uh well he sings
opera
uh that violent uh comparison is the
worst form of violence against yourself
and I think the comedians do it as a way
to just like cut ourselves and give
ourselves a hit it's like a drug addict
hitting cocaine or something it's a hit
of like self-hate and adrenaline which
turns into dopamine yeah why am I not
that big it's just white like because I
you know when people are like well
welcome I'm not doing this it's like
think about do you really want to be on
a sitcom did you want that you want that
the most lamest you're like oh your mom
will be proud of you fuck off you don't
want that you didn't get into this all
right by the way I can tell you right
now I'm sure you've got eight your mom's
not crowded it's like no her mom's not
proud of any of us
did when we did HBO together we did
Norton Show my mom after was like why do
you have to do that I'm like what the
dirty material is like no you pull your
penis out fuck I want to brag to my
friends and I can I'm like oh fair I
can't be thinking about you why did I
circumcise you that guy was such a fun
puppet show
but like I do think that it is our you
know I always say like with comedians
like complaining so much I'm like it's
taken because I feel like I get so much
negativity at me that I have to remember
like comedians will complain we like to
complain about anything yeah Gary
gallman 45 minutes complaining about
sugar cookies right yeah it's just it's
just our way so when it's when it's
pointed to you you can't be like I'm mad
about it you're like it's just dude it's
just point it just points everywhere and
then you get in there like wow that's
that guy I hear it all the time yeah
they're kind of like all right yes
that's wrong and it's like that's just
their way they comment on shit without
knowing about it yeah no one's really
looking for a fucking unique interesting
like full thought out take on a thing I
look at everything that I kind of
thought that I wanted it was like so
jealous of and I look back and I'm like
oh my God thank fucking God I didn't get
what I wanted because my I had such bad
ideas yeah I remember Bobby
Bobby Lee popular
Asian Comedian Bobby Lee was a
I went over to his podcast once a long
time ago and I brought some candy bars
and he said where are the candy bars for
I'm like you know what they're for and
he's like Ari what and I'm like you're
gonna put him up your butt Bobby that's
why I put him in the freezer I bought a
Twix that I brought for it's if you want
to go the easy way out and he was like
Ari I'm on ABC I can't do that I'm like
Bobby this is a prison you put yourself
in you're putting it up your butt
because I know who you are and if ABC
doesn't know you are that's their
problem you're putting this and he's
like well then I'm doing it right in
your face I'm like fair I didn't expect
that I'm not happy about it but then it
was right in my face as we're stuck in a
candy bars but that's who we are
one time yeah Bobby Lee and I were on
the road together and you know uh how he
would take Elmer's glue and like put it
all over his what hands and then just do
what yeah the only person that had to
deal with this okay so many Comics have
these stories about Comics pulled their
dick out that happened to me a a number
of times I thought it was funny but uh
Bobby pretty funny a soft dick is pretty
funny it is pretty fun yeah well because
it's also like it's uh yeah I mean I've
told the story about it LA Times was
just like they were dicks about it they
totally transcribed an interview that I
did 10 years ago it has this like
horrible like victim me thing you're
like no well advice this is the perfect
example of why like nobody should be
taking any Twitter you know comments
seriously because like comedy's meant to
be delivered you know what I mean the
joke is not even half of it you know so
people are like why am I getting
canceled on Twitter well why are you
posting jokes on Twitter where you don't
know where your joke is going to land in
between you don't know who people
fucking follows who's it being sent to
yeah you might get rid of a joke at the
comic store and then somebody takes that
joke goes outside and just tells a
random person passing by like this guy's
said the Holocaust was good why are you
forcing comedy on people during the day
that didn't sign up to see comedy you
know you're tweet can end up between
like Trump is running again and 10 you
know Elementary gets shot in the face
yeah it will be seen five days later
after there's been a school shooting
like oh no no and it's being delivered
by the idiot reading it who's in a bad
mood anyway who you know doesn't read it
right yeah with tone yeah and so for me
I was uh what is it 10 12 years ago when
podcasts were just starting we were all
doing favors for each other and doing
each other's podcasts you know it was
like super fun a really sweet thing is
it the fighter and the kid or the king
in the the
um worm those are both yeah yeah the
raccoon and the Jackal so the king and
no no
the fucking um fighter and the kid yeah
and so on but sorry they're both 49 so
I'm just trying to remember when it was
called the fighter and the kid uh and
the fighter and the kid it was down in
Venice and I went down calendar it's so
far away of course I'm gonna do it right
friends helping friends and he had uh
like pulled his dick out once like as a
joke I thought it was hilarious you know
I'd go down I'm not gonna tell that
story on a podcast to the person if I
felt
I wouldn't have gone we used this thing
at the comic Circle the problem is so
soft dicks are funny yes and so all
you're asking us to do not you but
people is not include women in our funny
right to be like hey you actually can't
come in we're having a good time and if
it gets out you were here for this we'll
all be in trouble you can't tell me that
I'm uh uh have been hurt and traumatized
by a soft dick that I saw that I thought
was funny right right right I I right I
thought it was funny yeah we had this
thing called cockings I'm never worried
about a guy comic graving me because I
can never get their dick hard anyway
you just have to be more annoying I
remember once it was one of my funniest
lines I'll say it now because you're not
the same person
um uh it was before your your boob job
and we were talking about the the pill
for uh hair loss and you were like yeah
yeah and and I was talking to somebody
about it and uh and um
you were like uh actually it makes a lot
of men have like uh erectile dysfunction
and I was like yeah but also when you
have really small tits
on pharmaceutical and a really big mouth
with a lot of opinions we did this thing
called cockings where you would just
distract somebody and then take your
your my dick my balls and dick and put
it on a man's like arm and then we'd
have champagne would be like distracted
like hey look at that and then you just
have this dick on your arm and you're
like what yeah
but we you can't do it to women
you just can't be involved because it's
just it's it's borderline victimy yeah
but you do it to a buddy and it's
disgusting and it's only meant to be
disgusting not sexual did you play
sports growing up yeah volleyball and uh
basketball don't you think like as I get
a card a what I fuck hard
that's a sport shut up in there you know
what I feel like as I get older I feel
like there's like I hate the word life
hacked I'm a high performer four hour
work week
um uh there's ways to have shortcuts in
terms of like managing expectations to
people that might disappoint you in the
future and does it ever help you to
divide people into categories like not
stereotypical or not like over
generalizing but people who played team
sports and people who didn't if I'm
interested yeah maybe or like an only
child or someone with lots of siblings
you can kind of instantly know how
serious this person might take
themselves or you can like make a little
bit of uh tennis players like driven
success it doesn't need anybody people
that were just daughters and swimmers
the fucking dorks it was all about them
but if you're team player usually you
have a better sense of humor because
you're in locker rooms and like putting
dicks on each other's chins and walking
around doing like purple bench and you
gotta like do what's best pass the ball
for someone else and it's not all about
you and it's like more of a collective
team effort because I think there's a
lot of like in our business there's a
lot of uh non-sports people
oh yeah that did not you know what I
mean even when I moved here I was
surprised I have a few Comics even knew
about sports not wild yeah and but also
not gay I mean did you see Tom Segura
play basketball that guy did not play
sports you injured himself getting ready
to jump until what a fucking loser what
a weak loser he was like gearing up to
jump and his body's like don't do this
what a fucking door oh my God the fact
that like people are worried about the
trans people are gonna hurt our kids in
the drag queen's like no it's gonna be
like gravity bro it's killing you it's
gonna be the 50 year old Uncle who
forces your kid to play football on
Thanksgiving it's like Joe Rogan has
made it so men in their 40s are now
trying to be pro athletes yeah and he
gives this false sense of security like
we can be strong work out like no you'll
be injured what are you
you did it wrong like no you're giving
advice to the wrong people you're giving
advice to yourself
I'm weak no one's drafting any of these
people we do this sober October thing
and I was like we're gonna do 100
push-ups and I'm like dude I can't do
these push-ups and he's like just start
with 10 at a time I'm like it's so cute
you think I could do 10 straight
push-ups but I maxed out at four but
don't that is good I feel like that's
been a positive thing being sober for a
month yeah but I feel like you guys
don't need to be like climbing ropes and
like like you know wrestling elk casual
yeah mid-life workout just get on the
treadmill how do you think everyone is
gonna die in comedy oh okay uh Brad uh
sorry Williams no no no uh sorry okay um
eaten by Bert yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly and then bird will just die of
fat right afterwards
um there'll be a few assassinations
hopefully I think I don't know I think
at some point people are gonna get the
balls you feel wronged enough that
social media makes people so fucking
crazy that they think they're just like
Ralphie called it and I think he's right
let me ask you something because uh you
have been at The Comedy Store um and a
way that very few people have and
because a lot of people ask me they're
like um you know what is this new thing
where comedians get assault I'm like
this is not new I mean I've seen this oh
yeah you know the entire time I've been
doing comedy wait for you outside
motherfucker oh I'll constantly and
remember and it's like fine but then
like can somebody seriously walk around
my car
there's like a 10 chance it's not gonna
even work at all yeah exactly some of
them jump start my car and then escort
me to it how do I break it to the guy
that's probably gonna murder me that I
don't have a car and I have to walk home
yeah I should call a cab oh the worst I
live two blocks from the store so I did
have to walk by I couldn't drive away me
too oh my God the worst part of that is
I would have Comics walk me home oh yeah
you live right there just up for me I
was like is there like a murderer that
can protect me from this comic David
Taylor said this is how long it's been
happening everything's just more
publicized now though like pedophilia
just started no that's why I think
everything is always existed it just
looks different yeah he said like you
gotta remember because he would anger
the crowd so much I started to keep
talking about him but he said the bottom
of the base of the mic stand is a weapon
if you pick it up this way shove it
anybody's off you you're crushing their
skull
so you pick it up like this you know
do you remember that time I think it was
Steve Byrne or Brett Ernst was on stage
and someone threw a chair I would see
see Burns a lot yeah somebody threw
something that Tammy pass could tell
someone threw something out in Texas she
tried to press charges and the cops in
Texas are like that's just part of
Comedy like you don't know comedy you
kept Ariel Elias just now that was crazy
and then the Jim Jefferies won I feel
like forget about Jim Jefferies getting
punched in my face that was just seven
more minutes yep and then he just
happened to be funny yeah you know and
then did you see the John caparula one
at Hermosa comedy magic club or
something threw a drink like it hit him
in the chest like a glass listen if you
can work up somebody that much with your
words
you're doing something amazing yeah
because if you're just spewing nonsense
everyone's gonna be like I'm out of here
but if you say just right at just the
right time to make someone angry or that
they'll hold on to their anger on
something you said for years you've said
something beautiful it's a beautiful
thing to get somebody that emotionalized
Norm said it like I'd like to make you
laugh but in lieu of laughter I'll take
anger yeah I just want you to feel some
and when you do it when you get people
to be some level of oh it's perfect you
got to say something biting and like get
in there do you feel like and that's
such a big part I think of what you know
you do and like what how when people get
angry at something hilarious and let me
ask you because uh to me when people
were mad at you about the you know the
Kobe thing many things my dad had died
in a really horrible way a couple years
prior uh I laughed so hard I mean I
remember thinking it was so much funnier
and I was like the people that were
upset I was like oh you just haven't
been in pain right you know and like it
must be nice to be mad at this tweet and
to not have gone numb already so that
this doesn't this feels yeah it's like
we're over you don't yeah I had some
people walk out two different old
couples who have been told by their kids
to go see Ari shaffir
um and they both walked out separately
angry complaining about me and they both
were like it's not just so much that
he's that he's like making fun of
children dying or being shot it's that
everyone else is laughing about it yeah
and it's like yo I'm just trying to make
people laugh but we're healing over here
but also if you're gonna be angry that's
also quite funny but you are the joke
but also how are you not taking this as
an opportunity to look at yourself and
it must be nice to have so little trauma
in your life that this is the thing
that's the most upsetting to you it's so
upsetting the fake imaginary scenario
we're just thinking about you got some
shit to work out bro meanwhile you went
and saw Saving Private Ryan where people
were getting and you loved it right you
paid money and thought it should win an
Oscar yeah it's just like work out your
own shit but it's fascinating to me like
I think that it it's just exposing dorks
it's so fun exposing dorks or Hall
monitors the people that wanted to be
the tattletales and and they might
mistake it for the wrong reasons the
right reasons one time I I had a I had a
joke about Adam West dying and I was
like fuck him the guy that Batman TV's
Batman oh yeah yeah and um and uh it
just I hate people publicly wrenching
their clothes about people they've never
met yeah they're scratching your clothes
like when someone dies they go no and
you like it's like maybe an old Jewish
thing or I should for a Jew on YouTube
right now you like just tear your
clothes out of like out of misery yeah
not mad pain okay um in fact when you
hear it
but it's it's a version of early on
Facebook where like um my dad has been
gone 10 years ago today you were the
best I'm like you were the best why is
the public post what's wrong with you
that you want everybody it's like you're
bragging about your pain it's so gross
yeah and I saw it with Michael Jackson
and Tom Petty and all these people
anyway uh I'm obsessed with the moment
that um famous people find out another
famous people die a DOT and the second
they do they go into their photos
yeah you're not like oh shit you're
looking for the photo of YouTube
together yeah when I heard Brody died I
was doing Molly in a fucking cabin with
big J and it was like fuck and it was
like I can't let this in right now but
like damn I'm not looking to fucking
promote it but you know what it is
fucking lack of humanity people I think
that most of this town I don't know if
it's this
I think it's like we are in a lot of
ways like I think what you know the
people that come for us now or whatever
this moment is I refuse to acknowledge
the word cancel culture and all that and
like it's so hard to do comedy that's
all bullshit I think yeah but I think
that we're very lucky that we get to be
heard in a lot of way and most people
don't so it's like that's their way of
doing it you know it's like them going
on Facebook it's like us going on stage
and being like yeah I guess and then
we're like observers so we're not
emotionalized by it we're just looking
at how everyone else is reacting to it
like Ukraine Russia like how do you feel
like I'd rather comment on how you guys
are seem to do yeah yeah well but I'll
tell you something a black Square for
black lives matter I'm like I'd rather
comment on whether or not that's right
rather than try to create any social
change that's not my job well because
that's the irony is everyone's like
Community do you think you know
everything no we're the ones that go we
don't know no no I think that seems
hypocritical though that seems
hypocritical what are you doing we're
the ones that go like the truth is
probably somewhere in between and we're
all getting conned and I think that for
us there's something so it's not even
nihilistic maybe it's just sort of this
like you know post-modern feeling of
like we are the truth sellers but at the
same time we're the ones that are like
there is no truth we've all been kind
everything's a lie and we're able to
find some weird comfort in that whereas
other people find comfort and this is
how it happened and this is what is true
like they need really hard ones it's
meta-modernism it's post-post modern
because look up matter modernism we're
still in the middle of it so it's hard
to analyze you have to like be past a
section to really analyze it right right
um but
um the guy who wrote Lesson Zero was
kind of the beginning of it what's his
name who killed himself Brett Easton
yeah he sort of started it and it's like
it's I can't even explain it just look
it up everyone really smart people are
named Brett yeah yeah because Brad Ernst
is a Brett I think of like v-neck yeah
he's like let me do push-ups to make my
check so better think of like the guy
that's like let's go to Vegas yeah like
the guy drinking on Southwest
this is not a part of you like a chill
dude yeah but also so calling out dorks
so I remember posting something about
about uh the Batman whatever his name
was
um
yeah and then I was like he had sex with
my grandmother tore my family apart he
knew she was married and he did it
anyway fuck him forever and then Moshe
Kasha was like he called me he's like oh
is that true I'm like no you fucking
dork I make jokes everything I say is a
joke and then it's like so wrong didn't
analyze it right but didn't get angry
but she's like what I'm like no can you
imagine like really no never really can
you imagine if I'm like uh George Lucas
called Michael Bay it was like dude just
saw your movie is there an apocalypse
did that car really fly off the bridge
that was crazy dude it's because we use
our real names or something that people
like take us as like factual and we are
saying sometimes I do believe this but
I'm trying to get some laughs but we
also I think that like context is
everything and like the signs of like
when you know when you're at a wedding
you know a wedding is happening because
there's a flowery Arc behind there's the
Vegas chapel and I think Comics it used
to be like there was a brick wall now
you're just talking but now there's like
you're in someone's living room you're
on a couch like people are getting it's
like when when Shane Gillis was uh
getting in trouble for that podcast
thing it was like well this isn't comedy
it's like well this is the first time
we're watching someone sit on a couch
with a microphone and it kind of like
that's what a conversation used to look
like I I just think I mean the the pain
of losing money of having to go out
there to you know promote like whatever
their sponsors or jobs to get your fire
is annoying but also it's like it just
makes the people who love real stand up
real dark degenerate Club comedy they're
just like it makes us feel more unique
you guys the holidays are just around
the corner so do not be left unprepared
for the season way has everything you
need to keep your hair healthy and
looking great all winter long plus
they've got amazing gift sets that
everyone on your list will love so I am
obsessed I've actually been using weight
look proof this is a new one but these
are from my shower as you can tell by
the weird like grimy stuff on it I've
been using this for so long
um because a hair
stylist gave it to me and I loved how
like cool the packaging was and simple
and like wasn't making turning your
bathroom into like a h r block you know
like they're just classy they're simple
and then my hair started getting so much
healthier you guys know that my hair was
really in a in a bad spot after the
pandemic whey is amazing because it
helps protect your hair from like all of
the like excessive heat tools and
styling I do blow drying I do a
straightener I do a curling iron this is
the first time that I haven't looked
like uh Phil Spector after a couple
months you know like it really like
bonds your ends it makes it so like
thick and healthy also the winter is
coming and the winter is very drying for
your hair this is such an incredible
holiday gift because you're giving
someone
like the gift of not having to blow dry
their hair every day to not have to like
stress out about their hair like it's
for me it's like I love it when people
give me a gift of introducing me to a
brand that I didn't know yet because how
would I have known and uh I just love
that this is a plus get it for the whole
family especially so that when you go
home they actually have good shampoo and
you're not washing your hair with a
little little sliver of Irish Spring
from 1987. treat your loved ones for the
gift of healthy hair special holiday
gift sets that take the guesswork out of
what to buy this season and they fit
perfectly in stockings or on menorahs
they have products good for all hair
types and with way better together kit
you can get the full-size leave-in
conditioner that has changed my hair
full-size leave-in conditioner and full
size detox shampoo for just forty
dollars perfect for gifting or trying
the best of way for yourself Can't Get
Enough there's also the three-way kit
because let's face it three ways or
better than one this kit features
best-selling travels size detox shampoo
leave-in conditioner and wave spray to
treat hydrate and style your hair look
at how luscious my hair is it's
unbelievable and when it hits me in the
face it doesn't like cut into my eye
because they're not all split ends
they're not like little mini uh samurai
swords you know look how healthy I mean
it is pretty wild I never I've never had
hair like this discover all the ways to
share Joy this holiday season go to the
way
t-h-e-o-u-a-i.com and use code Whitney
to get 15 off your entire purchase
that's 15 off your entire order at
theway.com code Whitney
this episode is brought to you by Better
Health as the world's largest therapy
service better help has matched 3
million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's actually affordable
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
match with a therapist if things are not
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist any time it could not be
simpler no waiting rooms no traffic no
endless search for the right therapist
learn more and save 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com Whitney that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash Whitney
I think all of this I mean this is sort
of comedy's better than ever it's so
much more popular than when you started
it's so much more powerful do you know
how many Comics take private jets that
was only for Mark Cuban when we started
it is 100 and also by the way like there
were no eggshells on the ground four or
five years ago you couldn't shock anyone
you couldn't shock anybody would have
gone numb everyone had to be a real
school shooting or like there's so few
ways to do it and now everyone was so
desensitized everyone's just like
totally numb and dead inside and no one
could be fun Trump would be tweeting
shit where you're like how do I follow
that how do I get a really well-timed
F-bomb now gay F it's just like oh my
God there's tension again yeah and you
might try to walk that line and fail and
people like fuck you we're done and
that's the fucking Joy of it great laugh
even journalists like whoever this
person is that's texting me like you're
a girl like death of Comedy no it's not
at all do a better more interesting
story but also by the way the death of
Comedy I mean you're writing a comedian
five community died this year do
something yeah you found this successful
comedian yeah so what are you talking
about yeah it's wild look at our tour
schedules like to me it's like you guys
have decided that comedy is dead because
maybe the people that you liked died
oh right you know what it is right if
you say comedy is dying yeah and then
okay
that's a cool story yeah let's do like a
death poll of who's gonna die next yeah
yeah it's bird it's bird but that's what
we were doing in the beginning look we
love Eddie I'm talking about comedians
dying but comedy definitely not dying
but there could be something this is it
I think also these people are too old to
go to other platforms to find the comedy
that is working so they're like well
comedy's dead I've been on Netflix and
Hulu and you're like no it's more live
than ever right you just need to go to
YouTube Just Gotta Go find it or you
know parlor or whatever yeah there's no
good up and coming uh music at the
Madison Square Garden yeah you're not
gonna find Billy Joel you're not gonna
find great new comedy on iTunes the
story used to be when we started that
though comedians are very funny honestly
stage they're quite morose and and uh
and a depressed off stage and it's like
dude you guys have written this story 50
times and now this is the new 50 times
story that's so I that drives me fucking
nuts for two reasons we're having a
blast upstairs number one they're like
well comedians of stage are sad and
they're bummers like you know we just
don't want to talk to you yeah you're
boring we're like maybe oh what's the oh
yeah we're not gonna bust out the tap
shoes for a journalist yeah oh I got a
joke you heard on It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia I'm not interested hold on
here's the other thing that hold on
Tucker Carlson wrote to you that's so
funny so this is uh uh vulture sent me
an email I'm doing adventure is hate
speech but get ready vulture I'm doing a
bit of investigated comedy journalism
for vulture I was hoping you might be
able to assist me I'm trying to get to
the bottom of the legendary who Jackie
story I don't know if you know what that
uh means it's an it's an inside sort of
um
uh writer's room thing uh there's a
reference to the who Jackie story uh I I
would love to talk to Whitney about this
blah blah blah and you know what that is
I know exactly what it is I wrote hold
on
who is Jack um uh oh I do know what it
is do not uh I do not want to
participate this in any capacity uh the
story is for trash talk you can also
tell vulture that they've always been
very rude sexist and disrespectful to me
and I'm not interested in engaging them
in any way print that you know what yeah
you know I started doing for journalists
quote-unquote journalist I break the
fourth wall and they'll ask me a
question and I go hey man is this what
you got into this for yeah do you want
to write the stories been written a
thousand times it's like it's like but
you guys you guys were trying if I were
to retweet anything that was written
about me by journalists 10 years ago
these people would lose their jobs in a
way that is so and I and I have no
interest Michelle always says they uh
she got a wolf
um got interviewed by somebody how does
it feel to be a female performer in this
world and she goes dude you you fucking
journalists are the only ones making me
a female performer yeah yeah I get up at
the table Yeah and all they know me as
the one who's really into aperol Spritz
yeah you know and then you're putting
you're seeing my vagina none of my
friends see my vagina but it's also it's
like I've been doing this for 15 years
what it's like to be a female comic like
I've answered this like I've answered
yes you know what I mean I don't you
know the answer to this is somewhere but
let's go to research and find out but I
also think it's more like uh that that
is just wild to me because uh I think
journalists the same with like TV
Executives and stuff they thought they
were always gonna own the microphone and
they were able to write whatever they
wanted and now we have platforms and
we're like hey remember when you wrote
that fucked up thing that wasn't even
true like the LA Times Circle remember
when you transcribed a podcast or as a
joke said you're talking about all my
contacts you know what you're doing
you're lying without lying you know what
the fuck you're doing yeah that and it's
so wrong and you're a journalist but I
forget what you're allowed to get away
with you know the spirit of this and
you're misrepresenting the truth fuck
you fuck your whole industry why aren't
you calling each other out for doing
that shit fuck off yeah by the way to by
the way to do that and whether
whatever's happening with other getting
none of my business but you to imply
that I drove 10 you know uh 10 miles
whatever to do 10 years ago to do this
person's podcast and you thought I was
like calling the person out calling them
a rate like that's what you're trying to
get away with and you're not including
the link because you know someone's not
gonna go look it up yeah and they'll
post a picture of you like a serious
picture like look what this story did to
her I'm like that's a that was a
headshot yes and you know and I'm gonna
be cool about it but you know we talked
about it you know we talked on the phone
and I said I have no comment and this
was a joke so if I say to you are you're
such a rapist yeah and then you're gonna
transcribe it as if I'm accusing you of
doing something how do you have a job
make jokes you guys tell us we're
serious but you guys are using jokes for
facts it's nuts it's nuts because they
were supposed to represent this truthful
unbiased place and you wonder why people
come to ask for the truth oh it's nuts
it's really crazy I I uh I I got I'm so
over them like Tim Dylan they called him
for this interview about Rogan and he
goes fuck off you're all pieces of shit
I'd rather have more fun with it so I'll
do interviews about my friends and I'll
just fill in with mistruths
legitimately legitimately I did an
interview and they were like how's Rogan
what's it like in the studio like well
he won't allow tomatoes in there he's so
fucking nuts with tomatoes have sugar
that he says I know I'm being crazy
about it but literally don't bring it
into the studio oh this is an article
about how he's allergic to Blue
um food no maybe oh oh maybe oh oh okay
in that case like I love it just just
lie just lie and have them be fucking
fools uh they said once an article about
his glass eye I don't think he likes to
talk about that exactly yeah exactly
exactly why is he so into fighting was
oh like well you know he was in The
Debate Club when he was in high school
the imaginary friends thing about how he
did you know about Thomas but his
imaginary friend uh tried to kill him
and he almost died and then he had to
learn Jiu Jitsu to defend himself yeah
is that not what this article is about
do what we gotta do is get a few Comics
together when there's a big story like a
Louie or something and it's like hey
everybody feed the same story and just
see if you can guys it's like he ate his
twin in his wound in the womb what if he
had a twin that's why he's so strong
because of stem cells dude he fucking he
is so Pro Choice he chose to eat his he
backed it up twin dude he aborted his
own twin yeah
he lost to abort he did it he had an
abortion as a male the front lines of
the trans movement dude you think I eat
a drink of chrome he ate his own fucking
twin why do you think he's so healthy
and made a pizza out of him it's so
funny I love because I love that chef
because it's just like I like stuff that
might as well be true like when there's
a rumor or a lie about me I'm kind of
like it's if if that's funny you know
what I like that that's good for people
because here's my deal about people like
I know how polarizing I am I'm really
big on like you love me or you hate me
like female Comics are the most hated
species of people on the planet like by
other female Comics buy other female
Comics too yeah God you guys fucking it
is interesting what do you think that is
maybe scarcity
I had somebody I'll tell you later who
it was but she was like I know that the
more female Comics join this the less
popular I'll be the less of I I'm the
only one I'm no longer the only one but
she was one of the very few yeah 12
years ago now she's not one of the very
few so it's like I don't know if that's
true I don't know if it's thought out
but also why do women non-comics hate
each other what is that what do you mean
women non-comics just putting those legs
out from under them all their friends
they all hate their friends uh uh women
do yeah I think that's a red flag I
think if a woman doesn't like her own
friends I think there's a difference I
think sometimes when a woman is
complaining with her boyfriend or a guy
she's on a date with about her own
friends I think that sometimes it will
masquerade as like you seem to hate that
person but I think sometimes it's like
when you're gonna talk shit about you
know it's a girl or whatever I hate it
when he does this and he took the thing
I'm not gonna go oh he hates sigura I'm
like oh no it's like when you're friends
with someone sometimes you still have
complaints about their behavior yeah
I hate this kind of fuck everybody just
mean yeah no I do a joke about it like
nobody hates women like women and all
the women laugh they they get it yeah I
know what that is uh because I think it
stems from like insecurity and I think
there's an also a culture of like I feel
very lucky as a comic that we get to we
could have conversations about bigger
things because nothing bores me more
than gossiping about a friend of mine
talk about life ideas it's the most
interesting conversations yeah I think
it's like a form of um like
self-loathing and self-disrespect to
waste your time complaining about
someone else's Behavior who's like sick
and suffering what's the type it's
Eleanor Roosevelt I think of like big
people talk about a little bit to talk
about what is it I love this quote uh uh
it's great small minds talk about people
small minds talk about people smart
Minds talk about events smart Minds talk
about events and great minds talk about
ideas great minds great minds talk about
sober October motherfucker just ideas
instead of like did you hear this happen
like the news stories are fun but also
like
like why do women like that kind of
thing is like an interesting
basis for a lot of it might be that
first it might be biological yeah and
we've been talking about every
television show we grew up on was just
girls talking shit about each other and
being Savage with each other you know
but I think that's also a younger thing
too I think as you get older you get
more calm yeah you just get a little um
uh you realize what it is you know if
your friend Rachel Simmons probably
smartest smartest chick from my high
school
um she wrote the book that mean girls
was based on and she does all this Like
Girls Leadership stuff and she's like
girls bullying a way that you can't even
stop it if a guy punches another guy
teachers can break it up but when a girl
sits down at a table with girls or they
all get up it's like teachers don't know
how to fucking break that up yeah and I
don't know if they should I mean it's
like just damaging yeah I mean it's like
we're we're wired to I mean the same way
men are but you guys are out like
punching the shit out of each other a
little punch and you're like I'm gonna
fuck your brother yeah why like why but
why is it you know oh I'm gonna fuck
your co-worker on SNL
now that I know when you do some gossip
about someone else you end up hurting
yourself it's like you point yeah like
why aren't you looking at yourself and
just trying to prove you see these
people online too that the addicts on
social media in the comedy world yeah
and it's like just go find something to
be joyous about yeah but I think that
we're gonna look back don't you think in
like 30 years the same way we look at
like people smoking inside 50 years ago
and we're gonna be like remember when
people could just be on Twitter 24 hours
a day with no limit it became obvious to
be doing early pandemic because there
was a moment when it was like Hey trans
thing was kicking off and it was like
hey this is going to make everybody
equal doesn't matter if you're trans or
fat or thin we didn't know who was more
more susceptible then it was just a
death sentence to everybody right right
first week or two and it was like it's
gonna bring us all together we're all
United in this common enemy kind of like
Gene Roddenberry would say if a you know
an alien force attacks us then all the
nations like let's work together
and then that lasted about a week and
then everyone got online when they went
home and it's just like anger maker and
it was just showed everybody how many
people they're supposed to hate yeah and
they're just doing it to us all the time
and we're just like can someone stop
them yeah and I think they're just
fucking paying off the fucking
politicians to not fucking regulate it
at all I also yeah I think that there's
also a very serious like the same way we
uh tend to miss addiction you know on
stuff so I think we're gonna look back
at this being a time of rampant
addiction to self-righteous indignation
the internal drug cabinet of when you go
fuck that person like when people when I
was trying to do outdoor comedy shows
and employ people during the pandemic
and people like you're fucking super
spread or cunt oh my God and like just
go fucking tend your garden but it's
like it's like first of all it's like
first of all you already didn't like me
you're right let's not pretend this is
what that I just lost you yeah okay but
if because it's never like can I talk to
you can I say something this could have
been like a DM or like a call of going
like hey you have five people at your
house in masks and you got tested like
how do you have tested how are you doing
this it's just like I never liked you
and I got my fucking yeah I I got my
reason yeah you want to do it publicly
you know you're being seen you want the
public if you're always blowing the life
right if which means going too long at
the Commerce store yeah there's two ways
to handle it there's to go on Twitter
and go Sharad small always fucking runs
a light fuck him or go to Sharon's like
Sharad dude we all have somewhere to be
man can you please stop yeah and the
fact that you're not the fact that
you're going to Twitter yep it means
this isn't really you you're looking for
some level of like clout out there and
there's a to me that used to really hurt
my feelings but now I'm like oh my God
you are making public not just Twitter
but you are making you're addicted to
shame you are making such a Negative
contribution to your future self because
what you're doing is so bitch yeah and
you're not trying to make a joke out of
it or any sort of fun you're not trying
to entertain anybody you're just being a
fucking bitch you're being a boy or girl
you're a tally snitch and you're like
trying to start Twitter beef instead of
just because that's the thing to me you
don't you don't want you don't want them
to change you don't have to be better
you want to say I call them out and this
is actually what I love about you and I
always you always talk shit to me to my
face yeah and I always have loved you
for it because I was like at least
you're giving me the fucking respect
yeah to do this to my face and I never
wondered with you like I feel like he
talked because we always know when
people are talking shit about us I love
that comics and female Comics they don't
know that I know yeah we're all friends
you idiot you think that your friends
aren't telling me exactly what you say
about me talking about shit about one of
your friends you're like but you know
I'm just I'm going to go tell him but
then also I feel bad for them because
it's like you know I I maybe there's
more of a we're all gossips there's like
uh my heart is like softer for female
comics when a female Comics like that I
know is really shitty about me or tries
to sabotage me in some way or like has
some thing with me and then I get fake
well yeah and then they're nice to me
and they don't know and I'm like just be
real just also go away from it but you
know what I want to do I want to go like
hey
I don't care what you said about me
because I don't give a shit chances I
probably agree with you yeah but like
you shouldn't trust the people you trust
right because why am I hearing about it
do you know what I mean I almost feel
bad for them because I was like you
should be able to talk shit to your
friends about people you don't like I
met says to me once because I heard you
talk shit about me she called me a long
time ago and I was like first of all
maybe I mean we talked about everybody
who told you that you have two names you
got to figure that out why would anyone
tell you that that's crazy we were just
doing Trash Talk dude yeah we all do
that about our friends it wasn't public
it's just like I'd be so much more
worried about the person that told you
than the person that said it yeah you
know that's a wild you had to talk to
some female comic shoes I saw her always
posting about me and shitting on me
whatever it's fine sorry to stand and
was like Hey funny set it was really
funny she's like oh thanks and she
wasn't ready to fight because she wasn't
expecting me to be there and did she
think you hadn't seen it no no is the
trash talk was before but you saw me and
she's not ready if she doesn't know I'm
coming so she's not geared up for a
fight and she's like oh thanks I'm like
yeah that was so fucking dirty and funny
and it's like thanks and then like you
could see later she was like ah fuck I
meant to hate him and so then later at
the cellar she's like she's like uh yeah
we're enemies and I'm like buddy we're
not enemies I think you're funny and I
like you there's no fight here I would
have to participate yeah what are you
doing you just don't like me yeah you
just don't like me stop being a jerk
we're all on the same team we're just
trying to write a better Dick joke I
think that when there were a couple
quote-unquote cancellations which we now
realized didn't take in any when the
Aziz thing happened when the Louis thing
happened I think a lot of younger Comics
thought oh if someone gets knocked out
from the top I'm gonna move up well it's
because that can get rid of you too
because I think you think the difference
Revolution I'm out of the way and you're
gonna move up in the pecking order and
that's not how it works well I will tell
you
one of these when that happened with Z's
unfair Lewy unfair all these people I
think are unfair literally all by the
way we're not hirschberg has such an
amazing joke about like we owe PeeWee
Herman an apology jerking off at a
fucking gay jerk off place in a suit
paid money yeah he was jerking off like
next to two other guys
I'm not going to see The Little Mermaid
jerking off idiot you just don't get
culture oh he was at a sauna no no he
was at a bath house that's a way
different thing this is a Joe Rogan song
Williams dude he's a bath house you're
taking out the context it's not the Four
Seasons yeah that would be weird it's
not that you've taken out that but but
all these wait oh one nice thing was
and then Chappelle also right around the
same time nobody was bumping at the
cellar the shows ran on time yeah it
wasn't fair but it was nice that these
fucking bumpers were gone yeah but yeah
I mean it just it I think that there's a
little bit of a self-cannibalizing I
think he'll get to the top selling oh
and also like oh shit his public has
public sentiment turned against that guy
I gotta also say I'm against that guy
because I don't want to be thrown away
and see I think that that's what really
stand up your friends you fucking just
for Comics so so this is something I was
just working on the only fans wrote like
a joke and it fucking bombed when I
tried to do it I tried it out at San
Jose of member Lindy West and Jim Norton
when they had that conversation about
whether you should be able to make rape
jokes or not and you know Jim Norton
very elegant kept his cool didn't get
emotional great debate it's a it's one
of those moments where you're just proud
to be wow he said everything so well hey
girl does your probiotic contain
clinically studied strains meet one that
does rituals synbiotic plus contains two
of the world's most studied strains with
over 350 publications of human clinical
trials so I've been using ritual for
years the omegas like the oil I mean I
subscribe to that like I don't know
three years ago and because it has a
little mints in the capsules I don't
like have to deal with people at parties
being like hey uh you're
breath smells like Wharf because like
the just fish oil pills like people just
walking around like smelling like a
quarry it was disgusting okay and then
they come out with a probiotic that
actually works it's called synbiotic
plus it is single nested it's a minty
capsule one daily capsule for simple
streamline God support delayed release
capsules they're designed to help reach
the colon not the stomach you got to get
to the colon for anything to actually
absorb and anything to actually make any
sense okay the uh colon is the ideal
place for probiotics to survive and grow
symbiotic plus and ritual are here to
celebrate not hide your insides no more
shame in your gut game that's why ritual
is offering my listeners 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
Whitney to start ritual or add synbiotic
to your subscription today this will
change your life now that I use it I get
sick way less I feel better I sleep
better my stomach doesn't always hurt
all the time it's a goddamn Miracle now
let's talk about another miraculous
product that has solved most of my
problems which are men having razor burn
and smelling like burning garbage so
this holiday season I am giving thanks
to my friends at manscaped I've been
working with manscape for so long it is
the only product I've ever given to guys
that they'll use like you know sometimes
you're like push like soaps and lotions
on guys I'm like oh no man like this
every I mean the guy that is in my house
like I just we have the product here to
talk about on the podcast and then it
like disappears the next day he stole
the the the the the razors the electric
razors he stole the little kit that has
the um the nail clippers and the
tweezers and everything in it this is oh
so good I'm obsessed with the smell I
use the deodorant myself but uh this is
awesome because the holidays are coming
up it's such a great thing to get like
your guy friends your brothers your dad
and it's it's more a gift for you than
anyone else which is why I support it so
much so they have a new package it's
called the performance package 4.0 and
some of it's for your package it is
absolutely giving me my money's worth
because guys are not smelling like Rat
Kings anymore okay he this dude I gave
this to he loves the product so much he
has like confidence all of a sudden I
don't know I feel like he's gonna cheat
on me he smells too good he's like too
perfectly shaved like I don't know I
might be shooting myself in the foot in
here everything you need for your man's
grooming needs gift your man manscape
this holiday season so his tree stands
taller if you know what I mean help him
join the four million man worldwide who
trust manscaped with 20 off of free
shipping with the code Whitney go to
manscaped.com I am so thankful that men
have manscaped to shave their balls and
get their grooming routine right get 20
off and free shipping with the promo
code Whitney at manscape.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with the code
Whitney at manscape.com get him the best
gift of all from manscaped your love
you not going oh
like the best gift you can get your man
and the man in your life is not having
to be like what is that smell oh that's
you
manscaped his balls well thank you
okay comedians like we don't have to
defend each other uh even if we don't
you know we might not like each other
but we should defend comedy together
because if you can't make that joke I'm
next and it's like I don't see it they
just see this the public sentiment
turning and they just jump on it
publicly I've had this where problems
like hey man that joke you made that's
fucking bullshit I'm like cool I'm not
going to talk about this but I'm going
to defend to the fucking death you're
right to be able to tell that joke yeah
and they don't do that anymore the the
George Carlin idea is like you have to
find the line and step over it
everyone's like yeah and then they
fucking shit on their friends public for
a joke it's just like Comics quick PSA
just air on the side of always defending
every single comic and you'll never be
in the wrong you'll just never be wrong
no matter what comes up either stay
quiet or just defend the comics and even
if it turns out like oh they committed
genocide then go well it was my friend
but this too I'm promoting is special
and it's like all these comments like oh
you got to come back you got to promote
it uh I'll make sure YouTube becomes
like the place for specials everybody
fucking wins YouTube is the place for
special I don't know for I agree with
you I don't know if it is for girls yet
I think you're wrong and I'll tell you
why tell me the algorithm Works in a way
that more arguments there are the more
it pushes you up and the number one
argument on YouTube uh Clips is chicks
aren't funny yes
they're going true true agree but it's
the same all these comments go and it
just makes these kind of mediocre like
five-year female commas is fucking two
million hits because it's like
everyone's talking on their fucking wall
yeah so guys weigh in on Aries if you're
a Jew on YouTube and say how much you
hate Jews whatever how women aren't
funny how fucking bald I look whatever
it is I don't know say something out
there say LeBron's not better than
Jordan whatever it is get a fucking
argument going uh I think it will also
be the place for women yeah at some
point women know YouTube women watch
YouTube
in the space yeah for like makeup and
stuff it is their regimens are big I do
get a lot of people that or like whoever
they are doesn't matter who they are I
know that like me a lot of people don't
fine but the people that do I think it
bums them out when they're they feel
like they need to defend me with
comments I just don't want the comments
to like be a part of something oh don't
defend anybody in comments just let
those people they're just showing
themselves how fucking what losers and a
half of them are trolls who are don't
even actually believe it they're just
trying to draw you in and I've been
fooled before but I'm like that's crazy
back and forth a few times and I'm like
oh you're a troll well played you got me
you got me I know you don't believe any
of this you got me and they go no it's
overdue but you got me yeah totally you
wasted an afternoon of mine and I I
think my thing with negative comments is
this like I decided for whatever the
only way I'm gonna survive whatever this
fucking nightmare we're in is is that
I'm gonna give someone a reaction that's
gonna make them feel better like that's
always just my drug growing up like
growing up now Colleen making someone
laugh making cutting the tension at the
holidays whatever but I didn't sign up
for how I made them feel good so a lot
of people feel better when they shit on
someone else it makes them feel better
that's great anything okay this oh look
at this fucking batch with the fucking
short skirt I just for a second felt
less like a piece of shit because I shit
on someone else so if you need to shit
on me to feel good great if you laugh at
one of my jokes great either way I made
your day when I said comments actually
wasn't talking about my own comments I
mean like if you're watching some like
music video and you see somebody say
something and you're like what are you
talking about kids aren't you know
that's what I mean arguing in online and
then so to get involved in your own
things so let me ask you though but for
you or if I'll see like a Joe list post
or whatever and somebody's like dude
he's not even doing this I just go hey
dude we're not doing that negative thing
anymore we kind of all moved past that
it's just like put them in their place
yeah I like that it is kind of it's not
about it not even funny it's just like
Hey we're not doing that like it's like
we gotta wear a jacket at this
restaurant yeah yeah but it also it's
like we're like 40 now yeah dude yeah
stop it's also that so the thing is if
you put your thing on only if it's just
two reasons to put out a special one to
get Hella money and two to make people
see it and The Best of Both Worlds was
great was was 2015 Netflix was that you
know you can make money and you can have
everybody see it
um
so you can make a lot of money on on the
offense really promote it and get that
shit so great well my thing with only
fans is this so the the roast that I'm
doing is on only fans TV that's free
that's not on only fans you don't have
to pay for it it is their first
television project so it's just going to
be totally free it's a website like
YouTube like you know uh uh Louis ck.com
whatever it is but all these jokes that
like you know I see all these Comics
putting their crowd work on Instagram
right and these like great jokes like
quick jokes and I'm like you're not
making any money off that but they are
how look at Mattel is fucking selling
out multiple shows Seattle and he's
doing the beacon sure in the beginning
but is there any crowd work that you're
like I don't know if I put this on here
I might well okay so you have to have a
standard for yourself you can't just put
anything out I've made a clip and I
watch it my editor was like oh wait I
got it down it looks good I'm like
nah this is better in the moment drop it
she goes well we need to get hits and
grow the channel and I'm like this isn't
the one but is it funny at all it's
funny a bit but it's not funny enough to
be put it on it only fans for someone's
like I'm a fan and I kind of just you
know I'll pay five bucks a month to see
him bombing up on like my patreon dude
but because that's funny in a different
way it's like an analysis of it but like
but like you have to have a stance since
it's all up to us you have to stand up
like this was a great crowd work moment
right or this I was just hacky buried
that and let me ask you a question this
is just a question because I'm obsessed
with like because only fans by the way I
think there's this um think of like only
fans that's where all like the horrors
are like have you been on it it's it's
like teachers that make 30 grand a year
making extra money so that they're not
having to like rely on getting shot in
the face of preschool since people like
well now what are you going to do when
when your body they always do this with
Karen fan what are you gonna do when you
get old I'm like she's gonna cash in her
fucking million she's making by the way
you know MILF is the number one search
porn the older we get the more fuckable
fucking pussy starts to melt she's gonna
make even more cash but the point is
it's like I mean Instagram and that's
what upsets me because you see all these
like like putting their tits out in
their ass and I'm like but you're not
even getting paid for at least put it
somewhere we're going to be getting
money from it you know so what I'm doing
for my special is I'm just give I've
spent way too much money on it but I'm
just giving it as a gift to people yeah
I don't have kids but the Tweet like I
don't have like a donation thing so you
can you can pay me a donation if you
want if you see something it's worth
something but like I get it but also
it's like
I don't know it's like giving ketchup
packets out of McDonald's like you're
not selling those but like people are
gonna have a better time and they'll
come back or soy sauce but I think a lot
of the stuff that that you do on stage
and a lot of stuff that you do as a
comic it's not you know I do something
slightly you know different obviously
but like that Kobe tweet I'm like if
that was on only fans where someone paid
five dollars and was like I get to see
the fucking crazy I am signing up for
the craziest shit the craziest shit no
one could have said that was fucked up
it's like well you're the one that went
in the gutter my paywall you said you
wanted to see that and that's what you
saw opposed to it just hit me during the
day
that is the problem of social media goes
to everybody but on stage it's like hey
fuck you for recording this it was only
supposed to be for this live audience
and I'm I'm I'm getting this crowd I'm
in a Vibe like Tosh like whatever he's
it's like I've gotten this crowd on my
side I've gotten it's not just oh that
joke isn't funny it's like when did I do
it I did 18 minutes in I did it to start
with it and also sometimes we're like I
did that one wrong it's like that's got
to be allowed if you say people aren't
allowed to fuck up they'll never take
chances and grow and get better it's all
from that like producers all from the
same place so at a show it's like fuck
off they pay to come here dark shit yeah
dark people that's it so to me what's
the internet version of that's only fans
and I think it's only fans you know and
so to me it's like you came here I was
doing this uh uh whatever I was kind of
trying to shoot the crowd work stuff
because it seems like people really like
that on Instagram I'm worried it's gonna
like train people to Heckle too much and
like want to be a partner and also it's
going to train Comics to start leaning
more heavily on crowd work than they
would do otherwise if they weren't
getting hits yes it's not like hey this
happened to be a great moment with this
Heckler and I got into it I wish someone
had recorded that yeah you're writing
for the response which is really wrong
because people like want to be funny now
that's what I worry about these clips
and everyone you know I went to I went
to a there's a there's a a cooking group
a bacon Chef group of of women in they
used to be in the west coast now they're
in New York and they all just make high
level Foods everyone make a dish and
they pick a theme wives
wait what yeah just someone I was dating
somebody once and they were just part of
this group okay um and every like two
months this is Comics trying to
understand what friends so they called
it and they would just make high level
dishes so when it was like uh spring
Foods or summer Foods everyone bring a
summer food and these women are all
really get into making some great dish
and it's cool and so one time they have
a thing called the Intercourse and
they'll invite men and so you have to
make something good and it was a
Halloween themed so I made what I called
column balls where it was just like
falafel but I don't know how to make
whatever Falafel balls and then like
this hummus with like but it's like red
so it's like brains and then on the
Falafel balls I just put all the names
of the victims uh and then three really
big balls of the guys who did the
shooting and the ones I knew laughed but
the ones I didn't know was like this is
way out of line and you're like oh
that's a comedian joke and I have a
pitch you should have done pickles uh
column brine column brine interesting
yeah yeah that's nice that's
face yeah laid down yeah so it's like if
if you don't get it know your audience
cool like if I walk by it wasn't for you
dude if I walk by like uh uh yeah it
wasn't for you this joke wasn't for you
if I walk by you know when you go to La
Jolla I don't know I keep thinking about
it like and you go by a store that has
like those outdoor Bronze Statues
not for me but I don't go in the store
and be like dude yeah I don't want them
so don't stop selling these it's like if
someone wants to buy them cool like I'm
just gonna keep walking yeah those angel
wings you see these fucking classless
fucking losers taking those same picture
yeah and you're like Ugh uh but like
maybe the argument if it makes you feel
good do it because I'm always trying to
think like what is my version of being
mad at a comedian in other ways yeah I'm
mad at those angel wings I really am I
see it you're like you're a loser you're
on original this isn't cute or this
picture I think it's walking away with
that you know that I think it's the new
Darwinism and we have to let it happen
do you know that 380 people have died
taking selfies falling off cliffs hell
yes should be more it's just arminism
yeah there's a video
of like it's like 300 people in India I
do not recommend watching the video but
it is a guy that is taking a selfie with
a wild bear while he's getting eaten by
the bear and everyone is filming it
happen
oh wow it's just idiocracy it's just
this is just Darwinism you know I mean
the people that are doing the angel
wings they're gonna die in a car
accident a couple days it's like the
same thing with the fentanyl thing it's
like it's like people like the fentanyl
testing strips it's not about the
fentanyl if you're doing cocaine at 40
and you die of fentanyl you were gonna
die next week anyway enough loser dork
loser wrong wrong drugs are great drugs
are great don't do Coke do every other
drug that they're fucking also putting
fentanyl in spawn live your life have a
great time don't fucking fuck up with
deadly shit your fun drugs
okay if you're doing cocaine if you eat
lobster every day but don't put fentanyl
in it but but you if you're doing
cocaine in your 40s the chances of
fentanyl hitting that cocaine are very
high now if you live in a dumb fuck
America move to the UK where
everything's pure
no that's not a problem in Berlin I've
never done cocaine
really in Hollywood not weird it is
weird but I wouldn't think you had to be
honest really I feel like everyone
thinks I'm on every drug no you're just
hyper I know that's the saddest part is
that when people think I'm on drugs I'm
like the most embarrassing part is this
is my personality what have you done
I've done I did mushrooms on a live
podcast like three months ago
how was that it didn't you know what I
feel like it just made me yeah take the
right amount feel less High yeah I feel
like I need to do it with someone that
um I trust who like is good at it I
think for me when I'm sober my brain I
just I'm on Prozac now but my brain is
so like OCD it's hard to focus it helped
me really just
Focus believe it or not I felt very
clear
I didn't feel high or it's a different
thing I wonder how much you took if
you're really on mushrooms it's not the
best for podcasting because you'll be
like
oh really and you just be thinking about
the truth in the universe and like it's
not the best to watch I was like
energized 15 minutes and then I've never
done ecstasy I've never done Molly I
know should we do a live podcast where I
do Molly for the first time yeah
never came out but I did one it was
great it was probably one of the best it
was probably the best podcast of 2019.
I'll say that without like and you
didn't let it out you didn't release it
it wasn't up to me it was up to the my
friend's wife who didn't want it out oh
right right
the best podcast yeah yeah uh he knows
it I know it there was never probably
maybe of all time legitimately
definitely of 2019 maybe of all time it
will be fun I will get you the right
amount as I got him the right amount uh
and I'll make sure it's pure we can test
it too again okay yeah it's a fun idea
but should we do it like well you gotta
get some you gotta get some we gotta get
some music too what's the difference
no MDMA MDMA
mxpx yeah mxpx yeah that's that's by the
way a straight edge band yeah I listened
to mxpx when I was a kid in DZ I was oh
yeah we're both I was like the Dork
straight edge Punk scene bitch and then
by the time I got to like school I
became like a workaholic and I'd eating
disorder so I never got kind of you're
straight edge not because you're like I
want to be hyper focused because you
were a loser yeah you didn't have the
stuff 100 that's it right yeah mxpx
cover or I just never got to do drugs
because everybody already thought I was
on cocaine so whatever no one offered it
it used to be ecstasy when I moved here
Duncan gave me my first type of ecstasy
and I was like and I was like I think I
feel it I'm I guess after like an hour
because you know I'm like I think maybe
and then it goes take another half
they're gonna happen like oh yeah I was
wrong where's my problem with it yeah is
I already have such bad anadonia that
the thing that I focus on when people
talk about ecstasy is they'll be they're
like okay look The Day After You Wanna
Live HTP you need to take a five htb tab
before you take it and you need to take
in one more 5-htpad tab the next day not
tab pill no because people will say like
for like a week I wanted to kill myself
but when you're on it it's the best it
is the best and it's worth it take that
5-HTP but are you doing it with like an
intention in mind or is it something no
no it's not medicine that's fucking map
shit but what if I
don't want to my fear is that I'm gonna
feel this amazing feeling and I'm not
going to want to go back to it's like
once you fly first class you don't want
to go back to coach is that what it
feels like yeah I remember telling
Duncan that one time I was like let's
take MDMA again oh no it's actually
let's take Exit again do comment comment
down let's wait a month like you gotta
calm down I have a very addictive
personality like I'll be like let's why
aren't we always on this yeah um it is
great it's it wears you out after it's
like fuck that was just a lot like
sometimes you're like you want to take
Molly and I'm like I don't have the
energy for this right now it's gonna be
six seven hours of real heavy
interesting fun thoughts ecstasy was
pure MDMA from what I understand I might
be wrong and then they started cutting
it with ass with speed and with other
shit and they still called it ecstasy
for a while but then eventually like
just call this Molly it's not ecstasy
anymore yeah uh which is MDMA and then
eventually they're like well let's go
back to the old school of old ecstasy
which is pure MDMA and then now they
call it ecstasy again and then that
started getting cut and then it's just
like whatever the Speedy kind
the kind of hat has been too speedy
but but also the pure stuff is great it
goes really well with mushrooms because
anytime you start going we're all gonna
die the MDMA is like nope your feelings
are great but we are going to die do you
want to forget it does it make you
forget it or does it make you have a
better relationship with the fact that
we are yeah yeah it makes you have a
better you'll fall I fall in love on
Molly and it's not like it's the drug
making you think that it's tapping into
your real feeling like it was with a
crow but right yeah you don't lose sight
of reality on it right we should do it
do you think that that each trip you do
like brings something else out in you or
like are they all similar or is it like
first one's the best because it's like
you don't know what it's going to be
like so it's all the unknown uh same
thing with mushrooms and then the more
you do it then we're like I know what
this experience is going to be same time
first time you fall in love you're like
no one understands that this is I'm the
only person that ever yeah
let's do actually let's invite a bunch
of people okay I'm gonna stink this out
here because I'm not even kidding you
have the money to do this right okay
okay nine paramedics standing by get
some paramedics doctor out I I feel like
I I could afford an hourly rate yeah
there's no job is Michael Jackson's
doctor Dead uh he must be out by now
right is he also princes can we get him
on the line
get some cameras set up all over okay
you want some people so because you
might want to wander uh you might want
to leave the podcast Studio where am I
so you put some Pockets like not just
over here but everywhere where you want
to go yeah you might want to wander and
dance you might need to move this chair
out but I'll get tester kits have some
paramedics outside so everyone feels
safe I mean but don't you think that'll
make me feel paranoid or no they'll have
we have them outside in the driveway
okay like but we also might want to go
to the pool
that's a fun idea yeah like have it set
up outside we can actually probably
should be doing the cast of characters
because I'm supposed to do another live
podcast in December it can be the it can
be the the Hanukkah I will be off great
in December I'll be off with my phone
off where are you gonna be just
somewhere I will tell you this when
you're on heavy drugs this is your
fucking best uh friend a little mole Sky
notebooks oh yeah and just write your
fucking thought of pure truth into this
notebook most guys there's rumors that
you're discontinuing the small notebooks
don't let it happen they are the best
for drugs for comedy don't discontinue
the small ones most kind please please
they're tear away Pages please the only
hard part is reading your drug
handwriting you are going to have carpal
tunnel this is the smallest wildly I
mean this is a little ridiculous but uh
this is a good suicide note Museum
vasectomy Bandit so that's the truth
moment of drugs write it down so you
don't forget it but you're like I see it
I see the truth you just the feeling of
like this is like the we're all one
we're all just a spec on the planet why
are we fighting that shit's so true and
then you like kind of forget the reality
is ever the the idea what happened we're
like you know what I gotta talk to my
parents more you know what and then it
goes away you get right right you get
right back into your job and you forget
it but like write them down meditation
can get you there too and so like what
you're doing is there's a knock on the
door and you could go get up and go
answer that door yourself but you have a
butler so you make the butler just go
get it because it's easier to have
someone go answer the door and it goes
the butler is is mushrooms or drugs and
you getting up is you're just doing is
is just meditation but my report to that
is if you have Butler money go to
fucking Butler yeah just why do
meditation every day where you just take
some drugs and get there if you have OCD
if you have trauma closing your eyes for
20 minutes can be very upsetting and
stressful right so don't tell everybody
else to and you can also re-embed neural
Pathways and make them stronger the
exact ones you think you're trying to
weaken with meditation so if uh unless
you have some kind of very specific
Mantra that's so for me the only
meditation that's ever worked for me was
George haas's class about attachment
strategies where the meditation is I
forgive you you forgive me I forgive
myself which is just I forgive you you
forgive me I forgive myself
you say it over and over again and it's
really just all about so you forgive me
part I forgive you no but you forgive me
as like you forgive me because a lot of
us went around all the time going like
oh well what if Ari's mad at me what if
this person's mad at me I think this
person's mad at me like they figure like
they've moved on they forgive me right
like and by the way chances are they're
not thinking about you at all at all at
all I'm a piece of shit in the center of
the universe but if you're just sitting
there going I'm not thinking about
anything why can I fucking I fucking
suck at meditating I'm such a piece of
shit why can't I meditate then you're
just actually exacerbated don't think
about a pink elephant yeah it's like
don't it's like don't if you have a
broken leg don't run on a treadmill you
know it's like if your brain is not
gonna fire the way that it needs to fire
in order for meditation to be auspicious
for you don't do it because you're just
gonna
strengthen the neural Pathways saying I
can't do anything I'm a piece of shit I
can't even fucking meditate I'm such an
asshole or you're gonna be fantasizing
about that your ex you know why did you
just do drugs do what works for you it
works for you yeah you know what I mean
just everyone's brain is so wildly
different like I feel like when I was an
addicts I can't do drugs I'm like sorry
I think the hardest part about all this
is everyone's just looking for people to
tell them what to do and the fact is you
have to like do inventory on yourself
and go okay this is where I come from
this is how my brain works like let me
try this and what works for everyone
else doesn't work for me I would say the
only thing everybody could do is watch
my new specialty
referred you on YouTube right now
youtube.com just go watch it and enjoy
it if you don't you're anti-semitic you
want a fucking piece of shit you are if
you watch this whole thing you don't
just go over there and be like I don't
know I'll give this a chance I also I
have no qualm with you you have a little
qualm what is it you didn't ask me to do
uh this is not happening
um interesting when it was going on just
as I said it I think you might have
I might have asked you to submit a story
what a lot of people did was they go oh
I'm in this higher not that you're doing
this but I'm in a higher place so I just
do it and then a lot of people aren't
used to dealing with somebody's like oh
no I need you to I need you to show me a
story you're gonna do yeah I'm not just
gonna put on a famous person yeah yeah
of course so for some people I was like
submit a story I'd love to have you if
you can submit a story
I don't remember that part yeah
um
oh we were searching for women
like hard we had to go to fucking
Indianapolis to find him as Pat like
they weren't around we were looking hard
for women what explain
you can't just say I want to get any
woman you need someone quality you can't
mortgage your quality for the sake of
these check boxes yeah but I get why a
diversity of opinion is right is smart
so we went to Houston to find Ali
siddique yeah it's not just well here's
the checklist of gays we can have the
same six gays we always use and also
telling stories like that that's another
thing not everybody's good at that I had
to cut a hero of mine once and I had to
talk to him like Hey man I don't think
this is going to do anybody a service to
air this and he goes yeah I just wasn't
good I'm like yeah it's right not
everybody's got stories I'm terrible at
one liner and not everyone's good at
Rose Joe yeah exactly same you know so
it's like and you see them like oh and
it's like try to get better at it I
would love you to get better and not
everybody has a crazy story you know and
everyone knows how to tell this crazy
story so it's like something had to have
happened to you that's nuts and you have
to know how to fucking tell it yeah Bert
Diaz big J Sean Patton Steve Simone Miss
Pat Ali they're both they're all the
best in the world at it but the same
story happens to two people and one's
going to tell a better another yeah so I
was looking for any woman so there's I I
doubt I didn't reach out in some way to
like get get me a story this is what
we're doing with podcasting
we're like the elders that are sitting
around the fireplace like passing on the
wisdom or something and I was like oh I
just want to like get better at telling
stories yeah then you just gotta do it
and fail are you ever gonna bring that
back I hope to at this point I'm done
with the special which was taking a lot
of my mind I hope to ask
two or three of my super rich friends
um to like just make it and get out of
my way and get out of my way yeah you
guys can own it but let me book it and
do whatever I want don't tell me who to
get or whatever I'll run it right the
way I did before right and I'll just
make it great again
uh I just don't have the money to do it
but I think we can make and I also want
to send it off right but also to shoot
it somewhere I mean now yeah just fun
stories get all the grades out there for
50 Grand sure something like that easily
yeah
um and it was like so much editing
before to do it for TV like take a 22
minute story make it work in seven it's
dumb why right exactly can I say
something else that is like when people
the digital ones were the better ones
when people are complaining about like
you know that uh like comedy's like
broken up into you know two minute okay
first of all Comedy Central hours they
were 42 minutes it was they break breaks
with five minutes commercials that's how
you're supposed to build up an hour no
like we've never had this yeah you don't
like go like have have the opener go on
and then he's like please welcome the
headliner do two minutes and be like all
right guys take six minutes go to the
bathroom I'll stop and then watch me for
another nine minutes and like all right
take another four minutes off
it's dumb so
just the people ask how long is your
stories be I go five to Fifteen but
someone like Jim Brewers was 22 minutes
was one of the best stories of all time
you don't get you don't make great I'm
sorry to call it art but whatever you
don't make great art by getting a time
limit and fit into that they tried early
on we started doing the show on on
YouTube only uh Allison Kingsley was was
the executive there and she was such a I
love her she's such a pushover she was
like we did whatever we wanted yeah
that's what made it great and she goes
uh you got to keep these short videos
I've heard two minutes or less and I go
oh I'm actually thinking like some of
these might go 18 20 minutes no two
minutes left I'm like we're gonna go
away go and then people tuned into that
yes milking it and really bringing us on
this fucking Journey yeah that's the
whole point it can be long it just can't
feel long right right right and you see
so some of them you'll hear them and
like hey this story is too long this
whole middle section has got nothing to
do with it it's like a brilliant
comedian was like I'm gonna tell you a
story I'd be like can you just like Joey
Diaz like I gotta start here I'm like
but can you just keep it to three
minutes just for no reason by the way
for no reason at all but it's like a
story that happened over a year and a
half it's like what do you talk it was
an epic yeah I love you are sorry I love
you too buddy I really do yeah thanks
for coming on I'm glad you're gonna take
your vacation
how about make 6 million this year
instead of 12. oh
have a life
by the way I spent literally half my
life savings on a special and it's not
that much so please go watch Ari shaffir
chew right now watch it now fight about
it you know I end these very awkwardly I
love you archfear.com touring all of it
yeah I've just announced the beacon so
first time doing a big fucking giant
room like that in March so I don't know
just tickets are available there but but
go see Ari layout theaters before he
sabotages himself and intentionally goes
back to small clubs because it turns out
uh being rich and successful makes him
to hate himself yeah it makes me
uncomfortable love you guys don't ride
elephants goodbye
[Music]
all right
[Applause]